[Musique]
ça y est on est au mois de marche
10/06 marche l'aide de madness begin
bienvenue sur envergure nouvel épisode
cette année à la march madness en
signait pas de diou pas des kentucky ce
qui nous permet de parler d'ores et déjà
des prospects de ses équipes puisqu'il y
en aura à la draft on peut en être sûr
ce soir on a parlé d' un contreur
d'exception à zahia jackson kentucky
mais aussi de plein d'autres choses
notamment notre dernier big board qui
vient de paraître sur le site envergure
point c'est aux alliés au mouvement
[Musique]
alors dans l'équipe ce soir manu bonsoir
ses pairs commentent soir voilà en
direct de sa salle de bain monsieur ben
comment allez-vous berthomé hommage et
monsieur pierre mikucki et la gauche aux
élections là alexandre de la data team
évidemment notre spécialiste régional on
va avoir à l'âne qui va nous rejoindre
en cours de partie puisque on appelle ça
une partie désormais c'est plus un
podcast et donc pour parler des jackson
mais avant on va quand même vous parler
un peu de march madness puisque ça
débute vendredi donc deux jours après la
sortie de ce podcast et qu'on a hâte
enfin les mêmes même les matchs
d'élimination vont être joués avant mais
les vrais matchs le vrai premier tour ce
sera vendredi samedi
donc on a hâte évidemment c'est un grand
moment pour nous c'est le moment si vous
n'avez pas regardé de la n6 est de toute
l'année de vous y mettre
puisqu'il ya des matches à enjeu il ya
des gros prospects il ya tout ce qu'il
faut pour apprécier les joueurs dans un
environnement optimal et puis et puis il
y aura forcément des surprises en fait
des matches serrés des matches qui
s'enchaînent à l'appel donc donc ça va
être un régal messieurs je vous ai
demandé de me préparer
avant on sorte d'apéritif
si vous voulez un joueur qui selon vous
peut grâce à un march madness gratter 5
10 places dans les big boys
c'est à dire les les classements des
meilleurs joueurs présents à la draft en
2021 je commence par toi pierre à toi
l'honneur qui aa
moi j'avais pris un joueur mais pas
forcément draft à lanfains compare pas
forcément la draft cette année et c'est
un jour d'alabama c'est lydia van quynh
orly alors john quinn orly tu as une
minute maintenant pour me dire pourquoi
il va exploser
alors john connolly parce que déjà il a
été excellent sur le tournoi des 6 6 il
a été élu mvp avec donc alabama a gagné
il a été élu mvp du tournoi il ya pris
mon qui est absent joshua primo c'est un
ca 2 3 et qui prenait qui prend des tirs
en sortie de banc pour alabama
donc du coup je pense que lui cbc et
donc john o'quinn arrive à récupérer ces
tirs la head on va pouvoir encore plus
s'exprimer balle en main donc voila et
je pense que si kun est relayée bon
alabama des grandes ambitions pour le
tournoi final en deux mots queen early
c'est quoi ça va vite ça chauffe
exactement c'est vitesse percussion foot
puis une certaine vista il vaut bien ils
attaquent dh 5 aussi franchement c'est
un gros talent ballon parfait moins
d'une minute c'est respecter ben qui est
en brique alpes les airs pour un march
madness 2021 mcsween s c'est souvent la
grande danse deitch geiss avait un
joueur qui prend soudainement après
quelques semaines c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi le texas tech kyle kendrick à
l'heure et nourrissent c'est dans le
fond un poste 2 qui joue pas cela à
cause de macmillan par espèce de chaos
intersidéral qui l'attaquent de de texas
tech et il est absolument terrible à la
finition mais c'est un très bon shooteur
de trois points et les texas tech va
voir absolument besoin de sa précision
et de son échec dans le fonds pour
survivre à moi je m'adresse donc moi je
crois que sur les bords est présentement
on va prendre foule va rendre
informer les patients sur twitter mais
comme tous les gars de texas tech il ad
énormes brazos quoi il a des gros
muscles ont fait de la muscu et texas
tech ne sera pas texas tech au premier
tour joue face à utah state
c'est pas mal du tout ça va être alors
ça va sans doute être moche à regarder
si on vous dit la vérité
ça va pas être fou il va emporter de
transpalettes mais c'est un horaire
traité sens puisque ça va commencer à
18h45
vendredi donc texas tech utah state avec
notamment le pivot portugais né millas
keita du côté de utah state qui est
candidat à la draft et pierre toi tu me
parlais de alabama alabama qui jouent en
entrée contre oyonnax et ayo nasa joue
un peu plus tard mais c'est un horaire
descend aussi 21h samedi donc et à yona
c'est pas si mal donc ça pourrait être
un beau match un peu offensif et c'est
donc voilà un belle opposition à toi
manu qui va exploser
pendant cette march madness s'il te
plaît moi c'est un collègue des coûts
n'est en lice d'alabama où compensera la
balle en poste oui henry ou herbe jones
mais moi j'ai besoin de petits moi je
vous ai choisis un sans faute hors jeu
limite sur la possible absence de josh
smith et une petite tente d'aider
videmment avec son absence sur le fait
qu'il ya un peu plus de ballons du fait
que les défenses soient concentrés sur
johnson petty et maintenant il va
réussir à sanctionner à 3 points
notamment c'est la meilleure c'est
vraiment un sugar un peu fou dans un
gaucher contre amir chacal forte donc et
en parlant de james goodnight dont on a
fait un podcast on vous renvoie vers
notre site et les épisodes précédents
james goodnight qui pourrait affronter
alabama dès le deuxième tour puisque
yukon et dans la même partie de tableau
que alabama et il a manqué un qui était
prévu dans le podcast mais qui vient
seulement d'arriver à l'âne en dit
bonjour à alan voilà comment ça vanne
super très bien meilleure période de
l'année
exactement meilleure période de l'année
qui va exploser à la march madness selon
toi je te prends un froid j'ai choisi
warchus de gabrovskyy ça c'est bien
on aime les noms exotiques exactement
c'est pas qu'il veut dire non si c'est
la musique que j'aime rappeler le jamal
murray du nebraska parce que je trouve
que esthétiquement dans l'esthétisme ans
ils copient beaucoup john murray donc
c'est le le meilleur jour je pense de de
créer une des équipes que moi j'ai
appris si j'avais j'aime vraiment bien
regardé depuis quelques années cette
année dernière j'adorais avec tyler
alexander cas du côté de phoenix entouré
mais c'est une équipe qui joue qui
jouent vraiment bien avec mamie du
bolloc'h mitch grosse balle aux gens
exactement avec le shooteur gauche est
déçu on dirait côté marcus et gars qui
sait le meneur c'est le porteur de balle
c'est le genre qui poulpe et je pense
que c'est un genre qui boxera junior
c'est un genre qu'il ya du massachusetts
à la base mais qui joua à crayton et je
pense vraiment que c'est un joueur qui
peut qui peut faire quelques quelques
cartons la march madness secretan valoir
sa sera pas ce que parce que ces gars
qui plante
bon en tout cas comme pour les autres
beaux premiers matches pour creighton
face à santa barbara qui pogne qui peut
très connu et qui pourtant 1
aux très bons prospects meilleurs
joueurs donc ça va quand même pas me
voilà mclaughlin en meilleurs joueurs
savaient une belle opposition face à
crayton et s'est pas joué même si
creighton et 6,5 et ue s you see esbly
pardon 6 12
ça va pas être facile et kristen qui est
dans la même partie de tableau que woods
hague a donc autant vous dire que ça va
être compliqué d'aller au delà du sweet
sixteen mais bon s'ils vont déjà en
deuxième semaine c'est pas mal voilà on
a fait le tour pour la march madness
on vous renvoie à la vidéo qu'on a fait
sheila first team pour vous présenter un
petit peu le tournoi si vous savez pas
comment ça fonctionne pour représenter
les favoris pour vous présenter aussi
d'autres prospects pas ce dont on vient
de parler mais d'autres prospects qui
pourrait briller lors de ce tournoi
final ça va durer trois semaines ça va
être top donc mettez vous au collège
basketball au moins pour ces trois
semaines c'est un conseil si vous aimez
bien le basket ball
un petit mot sur notre big board qui
vient de sortir qui est sorti hier par
rapport au moment où on enregistre le le
porte qu'à sortir à part donc puisqu'on
est mercredi jour de sortie maradi
sortie du big board on n'arrête pas
numéro 1 kate cuningham ben est ce qu'il
ya une chose que tu as à dire sur nos
classements généraux est ce que tu
penses qu'il ya un type qu'on classe
trop bas pour l'instant trop et qui va
qui va chuter
je voyais très peu entre les deux j'ai
coupé la poire en deux puis je veux dire
que scotty barnes numéro 10 je lis un
peu plus loin je crois que des numéros
15 j'ai absolument aucune idée quoi
faire avec ces c'est la grande énigme
pour moi de cette grave cette année j'ai
aucune idée
qu'est ce qu'on fait en nba avec scotty
boys donc d'être disent je crois que
c'était très positif pour lui mais j'ai
ces mots c'est le gros point
d'interrogation que j'ai cette année
effectivement un manu est ce que tu as
un truc à retenir de cette big board
quatorze des quinze premiers joueurs
clés assistons et freshman effectivement
à part de facebook lite donc c'est
inédit
oui c'est vrai après c'est souvent qu'il
ya beaucoup de freshman mais c'est assez
rare qui est pas de sots fomen et je
crois que c'est alan qui disent à la
dernière fois les sophomores sont
souvent un peu sous coté à tort parce
qu'ils sont pas beaucoup plus vieux que
les freshman et qu'ils ont tout
simplement choisi de revenir pour une
année de plus à la fac est en fait
parfois ça leur fait du bien
cf james knight donc et d'autres
exemples par le passé à l'année ce que
tu as un truc à dire ce que tu as un
coup de vieux à la passe et a pas un
coup de gueule mais est on m'aurait dit
ça avant la saison que qu'ousmane garuba
serait le quatrième européen sur le big
board
sa mort est un peu surpris tu penses
qu'on est trop bas sur ousmane je sais
pas je pense qu'il ya il ya le fait
qu'il est présenté depuis très haut
depuis très longtemps qui fait qu'on en
gare peut-être moi personnellement une
trop bonne image et donc il faut aussi
se rendre à la réalité du fait qu'il a
peut-être pas progressé depuis deux ans
dans d'autres compartiments son jeu mais
je pense aussi que ça prouve que mal et
cela si tu as les situations demi de
gars comme 5 go nous perd cassine comme
beaucoup plus de responsabilités dans
des clubs plus faible peut-être montré
notre mieux s'exposer mais sinon c'est
vrai je suis un peu dans la verse de ben
c'est que j'ai barre des 108 et je pense
que j'étais trop bas donc donc il râlait
bond est bondée moi je pense le paradoxe
coty barnes est aussi le paradoxe kilian
est ce qu'on pourrait appeler avec
ousmane garuba qui viennent ajouter au
mal et dos et selon qu'il est nice qui
était dans une équipe plus faible avec
plus de responsabilités maledon d'une
équipe plus forte avec moins de
responsabilités avec le résultat qu'on
connaît à la draft
ce qui n'est pas toujours la réalité du
lendemain en nba
même si on souhaite évidemment tout le
meilleur à killian et notamment qu'ils
se remettent bien pierre maintenant toi
tu n'as pas ton classement n'est pas
affiché sur le site
non mais tu as sans doute des remarques
car l'oeil avisé des remarques c'est
plus l'écart qui a entre vous et moi sur
béziers boston donc le kentucky
ça tombe bien qu'elle te quiero pour y
rester mais ouais moi je l'est beaucoup
plus bas il m'a beaucoup déçu il y avait
beaucoup d'attention des garçons il a eu
beaucoup de mal
après il ya plein de il ya plein de
chaque conscience atténuantes on va dire
mais quand même je je reste beaucoup sur
ma faim sur ce garçon qui pour moi
dans un monde idéal resterai ici encore
un petit on a peut-être été un peu tous
refroidis par là l'exemple de mcdaniels
l'année dernière en fait que ça c'est ce
que j'ai je pense à ça aussi il ya un
seul et même disque dur par la mer oui
c'est ça il y avait pas beaucoup on va
en parler dans le sujet et jackson mais
web pour finir l'année dernière
mcdaniels on l'a tous descendus petit à
petit dans nos board parce que il y
avait des questions étaient trop faim
ils arrivaient pas allez auxerre qui
avait pas trop de haendel etc etc etc
final il fait quand même 2 28 shoot bien
finalement il défend pas si mal il
défend même bien cette année à minnesota
et donc il fait beaucoup de bien alors
de là à dire que c'était un top 10 on va
attendre deux trois ans pour juger mais
mais c'est aussi je sais pas pour toi à
la ddt mais moi c'est un exemple qui m'a
refroidi en disant il faut pas trop
donner d'importance à cette année
freshman en fait ouais l'année freshman
chez les oies naines donne des cours aux
programmes j'essaie toujours de prendre
avec des pincettes mais c'est un
contexte il ya d'autres contextes
je pense qu'il faudra aller voir autre
chose sûre sur le bitume au sol même si
dans le temps la 9e et avant la saison
tout le monde est d'avis top 5 donc
c'est quand même qu'il ya eu 17 prix sur
sur sa saison oui moi ce que j'avais vu
au lycée je l'avais dans les trois
premiers et donc j'ai baissé absolument
il est l'heure il est là on sonne la
cloche il est l'heure du débat du débat
la présentation à zahia jackson donc on
reste à kent utilise ça tombe bien on
parlait de brandon boston juniors n'ont
pas junior run this town on sait jamais
si c'est jugnot vite et c'est ça
kentucky qui ne qui n'est pas la march
madness et j'ai besoin de quelqu'un pour
me présenter à zahia jackson puisque
évidemment la plupart de ceux qui nous
écoutent je pense ne l'ont pas vu jouer
et donc ce quelqu'un évidemment ces
bennes qui va nous brosser un petit
portrait rapide
oui anecdote un peu drôle j'ai eues
j'étais mieux au courant de l'existence
de deux de kentucky cette année parce
qu'elle une erreur cléricale soit sa
ronde en vigueur et s'était dit qu'il y
avait une envergure de 7,6 à pied 5 et
il a une envergure
au regard de ces points 0,5 mais ça
m'intrigue et parce qu'avec ce poste 4
qui fait 6 10 ce qui fait qu'ils très
très fin qui fait 206 livres moi je peux
vous donner une comparaison le joie le
plus prêt que je peux voir de jackson
pour le vus à kentucky et quelques
années c'est noël noël qui joue
maintenant pour les knicks de new york
un poste capte avec des talents et de
post 5 c'est à dire qui peut le défendre
vraiment très très bien
extrêmement rapide qui saute très haut
qui ont une excellent timing pour
protéger sec
il est assez rapide et explosif aussi
pour switcher au périmètre pour attaquer
un peu répond t qui dort en a cinq mois
c'est un type de joueur que j'aime
beaucoup parce qu'il fait ils maîtrisent
quelque chose c'est à dire qu'il ya une
carte d'affaires avant ça veut dire moi
el mouahidia jackson je suis spécialiste
la défensive et lorsqu'on voit un poste
4-5 comme ça on a toujours besoin d'un
hyperactif qui va chercher des rebonds
qui va mettre des pôles bac et qui va et
qui va faire des contres et je pense
qu'il l'a il dort en moyenne 2.6 contre
cette année ce qui est absolument énorme
pour un joueur dansiez i love timing il
a une explosivité et leurs facteurs et
d'imitations qui est vraiment très
offensive au parloir
selon ce on
il a une efficacité de 54% qui est
majoritairement au panier je crois pas
qu'il ait trois bijoux et eu de shu mais
il n'en a pas fait un règle non il n'a
pas mis à zéro sur la première version
de son son tir n'est pas dégueu y sont à
70% à 3 points aux lancers francs
panneaux lancers francs sa mécanique de
tir n'est pas brisé mais sont à foix son
attaque est très très très c'est à dire
que côté la grande attaque il est
meilleur qu'eux il est capable de se
mettre en position pour faire du dommage
mais pour l'instant il m'a fait très peu
ou pas du tout ça faisait bien sûr
spécialiste défensif et sombre où
d'habitude en début de deuxième taux ne
dit pas tout monsieur monsieur lelièvre
donc on
on me parle d'un joueur qui est quand
même assez intéressant notamment
défensivement alors même s'il n'est pas
né rollins noël à l'époque défensivement
qui était à plus de deux interceptions
et 4 contres et demi par match quand
même c'est c'est fou mais je vois aussi
qui joue moins et donc là je me tourne
vers vers pierre qui a suivi toute la
saison de kentucky
quel rôle il avait sur le terrain kg
quel rôle au sein de l'effectif pourquoi
il joue vingt-et-une minutes par match
alors que là on est en train d'en parler
comme d'un prospère intéressant alors il
serait de bon ton de cracher sur télé
paris mais pour une fois c'est pas
totalement de sa faute c'est à dire que
c'est l'airé garçon qui a la fâcheuse
tendance à être en folklore beuls et
donc du coup qui a fait sa hotte sur 6
des 25 matchs de kentucky il a start et
18 x 125 est donc ici pour six fois il
est sorti pour cinq fautes et il ya même
la finit à dix fois plus de cas de
fautes donc fin à quatre fautes ou plus
donc c'est énorme donc il ya un gros
problème de ce côté là il ya un côté
assez naïf par rapport à son style de
jeu ça va voir qu'ils cherchent le
contre et donc du coup qui quelquefois
se fait aussi à voir donc forcément ça
là ça endommagé les stats brut on va
dire après dans son rôle et y jouer et
est souvent mis à côté d'olivier sarr
olivier sarc cette capacité a plutôt
stretch et on va dire et c'est lui qui
était plus dans les courses et dans
l'évident dans les flashs
dans les flashs au ballon et voilà après
il y avait toujours le problème de
kentucky cette année avec le gard le
gameplay qui était juste calamiteux et
affreux donc et malheureusement il n'a
pas pu briller mais on note quand même
sur ces derniers matchs qu'il a vraiment
il a augmenté sa moyenne de points j'ai
fait le calcul
sur les sept derniers matchs qu'il a 13
3 par match donc ce qui est beaucoup
mieux que ce qu'il a présenté le tout à
63 % de réussite
voilà donc donc en progression quand
même mais il y avait il y avait quand
même un peu de concurrents sur son poste
4 il pouvait pas vraiment joué cinq
puisqu'olivier sarr joué beaucoup c'est
ça exactement
c'était c'était assez compliqué est
aussi le frère taux de pin y avait enfin
voilà il y avait du monde à un moment
donné ouais ouais aussi donc
l'asnl en dessous r ouais donc enfin un
petit bond qu'elle y paraît on sait si
ça marche pas en plus ils essaient
toutes les formules donc du coup
forcément ça c'est au détriment des
joueurs donc
donc voila et tout ça a fait que
effectivement 20 minutes par match et
donc mais par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est de regarder ses stats
sur quarante minutes où la hausse et
c'est là où ça devient assez affolant
oui on est sur 5 contres par match sur
quarante minutes du coup puisque de
l'a26 compte sur le nouveau ouais ouais
quasiment 13 rebonds c'est très
intéressant vous pouvez l'oeil sur sur
sa fiche
évidemment que tu a misé sur envergure
point ces os pourra voir les stats sous
les yeux en même temps qu'on parle je
mens pratiques justes je redonne les
mensurations puisque ben les a donnés en
pour nos amis outre-atlantique 2009 93
kg alors du coup envergure à vérifier
puisque nous on à 2,19 peut-être
beaucoup on verra on vérifiera ça plus
tard mais en tout cas il n'a pas des
petits bras peut-être pas des très longs
bras mais pas des petits bras manu j'ai
besoin donc ben a parlé d'un joueur très
athlétique d'accord
que tu besoin que tu me donnes ses
qualités évidentes en fait qu'est-ce qui
qu'est ce qu'on achète si on draft à
zahia jackson en fait on se met dans la
peau d'un gm défense j'imagine défendre
sur toutes les positions a bien essayé
un an ou celle que je vois que
directement chez lui avec un second jump
vraiment vraiment intéressant tout ça
est quelque chose là complet me font
dire que pour moi tiens un prospect king
dans le topo distingue c'est pourtant
dans mon porte d'ailleurs clairement
orange l'a dit moi je laisse pas passer
parce que j'imagine beaucoup de choses
que défense sur l'homme se soit défendu
cercle car mon stade l'a choisi parce
que avec une mobilité dingue pour un mec
de 9 à ce qu'il y ait une brave immense
je pense pas qu'il soit de 10 mais je le
trouve assez non tout ça glace est
principalement sa défense que je vois
vraiment comme le truc sur un peu à la
brandon clark
si on compare à joueurs récent drafté
qui était pas une flèche forcément
offensivement notamment au niveau du
shoot qui ça va ça vient
mais défensivement très fort ouais ça me
ouais je pas de choquer par sas est par
contre tout comme comparaison alan j'ai
besoin que tu me dises toi qui regarde
beaucoup de nba quel genre de rôle dans
la nba d'aujourd'hui à z jackson
pourrait avoir parle d'un mec qui peut
switcher partout qu'elle tu vois quel
rôle il peut avoir dans cette dans cette
veine billets est-ce qu'il va sortir du
banc à ce qui serait titulaire à côté de
quel type de profil évidemment ça dépend
des coachs mais en règle générale
et puis qu'est-ce qu'il aura besoin
d'ajouter ensuite à son jeu pour arriver
vers ce rôle espérer le fait qu'il
shoote pas à trois points fait qui
devrait être le seul meneur shooteur
le terrain dans son début de carrière
avoir deux noms shooter à trois points
en nba aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
c'est très très peu d'attac qui arrivent
à survivre comme ça donc il faudra soit
qui joue sans qui est qu'ils jouent à
côté d'un ailier qui vaut post 4 ou
alors si on vous le faire jouer au poste
4 il faudra un vrai stretch wade voilà
la boucle lopez un jour dans ce jour là
ce sera pas possible pour lui dans son
débuté hier de jouer
post 4 avec un pivot à côté ça serait
qu'il ne chute pas ce sera ce sera pas
possible pour le pôle speaking donc je
pense que ça sera typiquement un joueur
qui y sera je pense backup file on sait
backup 5 dans ses premières années qui
j'aurai une 15 15 20 minutes
et si on s'il arrive voilà son nagra de
développer son c'était peut-être sa pâle
et aux fossiles parce que c'est très
très brut cédant là c'est un genre de
fin de chaîne c'est que d'art que de la
fin de chaîne pour l'instant même s'il
ya des petits petits ou coûte étaient
tous comme ça ce sera pour moi dans ses
premières années un bon un paquet pour
le bon back up
et puis potentiellement crimes qui
peuvent et qui peu à peu prendre des
minutes en tant que titulaire mais avec
pour le moment la nécessité d'avoir que
des shooteurs autour parce que sinon
prospecting sa manche au rebond donc
quand on récapitule force principale
évidemment la défense switch habilité le
côté efficace près du cercle on va
peut-être en reparler mais en tout cas
au dessus du cercle évidemment l'ofppt
target cible pour les allées où le côté
aussi jeune on en a pas parlé mais c'est
un des rares 2002 près qu'on a mis dans
notre top 20 pour le moment il ya pas
mal de 2001 même chez la classe de
freshman donc là je compte également ses
rangs des joueurs les uns des candidats
les plus jeunes
asia jackson maintenant on a parlé de
ses forces principales on a parlé de sa
faiblesse principale du coup le tir quel
autre facette de son jeu vous avez pu
voir et là du coup part régulièrement
qui saute pas aux yeux mais en
l'observant beaucoup jeu peut-être venir
vers toi pierre d'abord qui a vu qu'elle
a vu pas mal de matches qu'elle quel
autre facette du jeu on pourrait voir en
développement que ce soit un aspect un
peu plus leader leadership c'est à dire
mon mental ou en tout cas connaissance
du jeu où que ce soit un aspect purement
technique dans la palette offensive
ouais après donc le couple a dit alan
c'est vrai que ça à voir très brute
voire de fin de chaîne après dance qui
dégage sur le terrain c'est un joueur
qui voilà qui nous qui dégage pas grand
chose en tels qu'éric al je trouve
relativement neutre et qui semble très
fair-play aussi moi je dirais que
plusieurs fois relevé un adversaire
relevé ces gars d'être un bon gars par
contre à l'ofce donc ça c'est plutôt
bien
après on voit là offensivement il n'y a
rien comme c'est c'est très compliqué
enfin on l'a jamais vu avec eux balle en
main comme ça se fait beaucoup
maintenant avec des pivots qui sont
capables de passer au l'âge est
quasiment jamais vu à la passe moi ça va
ça ça m'a m'interpelle adipeux savoir
est ce qu'il est capable au moins de
faire des lectures basique on lui
demandait jamais de faire sa demande et
lui souvent c'était d'être près du
cercle et de d'être avec eux un espèce
de seul pour avoir pour voler rebonds
offensifs rooney que lui c'était juste
ça son rôle c'était de gratter des
ballons et remonter mais dedans quoi
grosso modo donc c'est vrai que ça il ya
beaucoup d'interrogations mais après on
va avoir des bonnes surprises kentucky
on habitue emmanuel kakou clé un exemple
merveilleux pour moi mais faire alors un
pas en parlant du club n est-ce que
jackson peut avoir un skill ce qu'il
cède caché par par coach calipari par le
système kentucky
je vais dire un peu mon ressenti mais
moi j'ai l'impression que je les ai vus
au moins driver s'en passer pierre a
raison mais au moins driver prendre de
vitesse du coup son adversaire direct
quelquefois pas de manière régulière
mais quelquefois à absolument moi je
crois qu'ils leur rôle vraiment très
serré qu'on lui a donnée à ken keen lui
a probablement pas rendu service
plusieurs fois ci on accroît ses
entrevues il est capable de dribbler
shooter de créer son shoot et il voulait
jouer et il refusait de jouer pasta cas
dépasse 5 lorsqu'il était au lycée il
voulait jouer poste de passe qui disait
que c'est là qu'ils en étaient les plus
impliqués à la tact bon sa chanson a
changé depuis ce temps là mais on parle
de joie je crois qui est conscient qu'il
lui manque qui lui manque des choses qui
pose sa main ou qui doit travailler sur
des petites nuances de changer comme ça
en effet ce un bon driver je crois que
halak droite ou sans même le ballon il
pourrait être son athlétisme pourrait
vraiment être plus pour lui rappeler ce
qui n'arrive ce n'est vraiment pas lourd
donc ça l'upa m courir oui c'est vrai
pour l'instant très léger manioc
justement est ce que c'est
qui est ce côté un peu il n'a pas de
grosses et polis l'est pas il n'a pas
l'impression qu'il va prendre énormément
de poids en fait elle est à jackson et
je sais pas alors je vais chercher en
même temps que je parle sais pas si vous
l'avez voulu sa réussite au cercle
mais j'ai pas l'impression que 68 68 %
au cercle et à 35% à mi-distance tu
parfait pierre 68% serre ce qui est bien
et ce qui est très bien mais pas ici au
canada tim gleason ouais c'est ça un
chiffre demandez à laure manu que
qu'est-ce que ça t'inquiète le gabarit
qui pardon de az jackson du tout je
pense qu'il va pouvoir ajouter quelques
lui ce que parce qu'ils parlent à
nouveau nous mener au niveau des bras ce
match plus que s'il va pas volume commun
en tête des listes par exemple il est
vraiment des moments plus frêle au début
aussi est une qui l'était pas il n'était
pas le plus de quêtes son équipe mais il
a professor au fil des saisons et je
vois un peu cette même chose là sans
aller jusqu à hélices aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment ultra loire entre les deux
mamans en quoi on n'est pas contre ce
qu'il faut pour son jeu pour qu'il faut
nous pensons pas à même de tenir le choc
l'état est en en ennemis alan est ce que
tu as une observation à faire sur les va
dire les skis le secondaire de notre ami
jack ce pas déjà je trouve que l'on sait
francs il a une belle mécanique
franchement je trouve que c'est plutôt
correct et j'avais lieu comme quoi en
fait
quand il jouait en fait il avait clamé
lowball haut risque où tout le monde a
joué avec la menace par ailleurs
il joua spyer avec lui et en fait de ce
qui se dit un peu c'est que il n'y a pas
eu du tout était bon c'est normal en
service la même manière par le mélo bola
supérieur que par les coins il avait
cette année qui inclut qui est donc à
royan walikale aux nouveaux participants
exactement donc en gros il n'a pas été
mise en valeur sur sa queue même il
s'est un jour qui faisait du pic npo
mans en lice et de ce qu'ils se disent à
mi-distance ans donc et moi j'ai trouvé
franchement que sa mécanique elle était
plutôt solide il arrête tout 70 % pour
un juge et un intérieur de 101 postes 5
de son âge c'est même assez bien après
après défensivement il est aussi à
l'aise sur leur mission le week size
il est il est monumentale il est
g ban a dit le nombre de comptes en fait
de compter sur le talent c'est 13% de
contre
c'est dans le zénith élite n 6 de blain
pour tous les joueurs de toutes les
conférences
donc en termes de protection de cercle
c'est incroyable comme le disait pierre
deux coups le le ce qui contrebalance ça
c'est le nombre de fautes
qui est souvent un vrai défaut chez
jeanneau intérieur en nba qu'on souligne
pas beaucoup parce que c'est rare qu'ils
jouent plus de 20 25 minutes mais mais
qu'il va falloir gommer avec l'âge
souvent ça se gomme un peu tout seul
mais pas toujours
ben est ce que quelqu'un une autre
marque sur alzette jackson je vais juste
donner rapidement son classement il est
20e de big board pour le moment donc
c'est un consensus évidemment manu est
très haut il la 11e ben est très bas non
c'est le plus bas d'entre nous la 32e
moi je suis à 30 et alan est à 24
donc dans l'ensemble au premier tour
même si bénézit
est ce que quelqu'un a une remarque à
faire sur asia jackson est d'abord
pierre est ce que toi si je suis pas si
un big boy mais est-ce que tu le
classerait à peu près dans ces eaux là
ouais complètement ou autre vas et tu
rentres veut voler dans ces eaux là
après moi je suis toujours embêté par ce
genre de profil dans le sens où
effectivement il y a quand même un cruel
manque de kilos 93 kg c'est quand même
très très très léger et au par exemple
enfin moi j'ai le dernier match de
kentucky c'était contre mississippi
state et les intérieurs de kenji ont
pris la marée emprunt mi temps et se
sont fait défoncer quoi parce qu'il ya
débat bar en face et ils ont pris l'eau
donc moi salsa samba
ça me reste un gros frein après le
potentiel athlétique est incroyable
franchement c'est un flic de dingue
et c'est vrai que sur le départ en
dribbles il ya aussi quelque chose quoi
quand il est arrivé à se remettre face
au cercle
c'est quand même super intéressant faut
pas lui demander de faire trop d des
mouvements au poste bas mais pour bien
utiliser il peut être vraiment
intéressant c'est clair on vous
conseille quand même de regarder
mississippi state des highlights sur
youtube il ya que des mecs qui font dix
heures de muscu par un jour une
demi-heure de basket c'était tout
une équipe de bûcherons c'est assez fou
absolument
avec robert boudard derradji perry
l'année dernière pour ceux qui les
connaissent un peu en nba basse et de
même genre prenez ce moule à avec des
biens larges épaules
d'autres remarques sur la côte d'azur
jackson elle va monter elle va descendre
elle va rester la même
et kelly paris va le vendre dans le tri
elle va monter jeu elle va monter les
codes qu'elle te qui m'ont toujours dans
le graf c'est vrai et même ça reste un
pinot un pivot mais il y en a pas
beaucoup avec ce profil là à l'année des
switchs rôle pivot la de tête peut-être
kyle jones mais encore on n'est pas sûr
ouais délire mais mais ça reste un
ça c'est en intérieur donc revoir
comment il va être évaluée et comment
sont profilées et peut-être dévalué par
les franchises nba là mais les
intérieurs mais oui mais coach non la
haine là la nba mais là tu sais on peut
switcher qui peut faire du rôle enfin tu
vois bob williams il a été drafté à peu
près entre 18 et 25 ans
peut-être en 27 c'est un peu le profil
se profile mais beaucoup d'hommes qui
est tombée aussi et pas seulement sur
terrain je pense pas qu'elle ait truc en
termes oui il manque un une ou deux
quinze jours c'est ce qu'on nous avait
dit je pense qu'il peut être dit pat me
away complètement mais en tant que fan
de bruce sohn
après je suis pas sûr que notre ami à
jackson soit nettement au dessus parce
qu'ils la gagnent 10 dans sa danse à
bios de du kentucky que son film préféré
l'incroyable hulk donc moi ça me laisse
un petit peu dubitatif s'isoler mais bon
après tout les goûts sont dans la nature
c'est lequel l'incroyable hulk est
plusieurs films c'est trop vous demander
là celui avec à droite tu vois je pense
que c'est une issue avec edward norton
déjà et 2001 à wes esata raison celui
avec edward norton bon 2000 2008
c'est pas le meilleur film des noirs à
retenir est qu après pas du tout pas du
tout ben ben qui connaît bossi le cinéma
pour ceux qui veulent aller
dire cesser ses chroniques et tu essaies
créé en anglais ou sacre en france n3
bannière point c'est bon ouais la passe
placement produit que foncer comme en
mai alors on passe on passe à la suite
ou pas non vous avez d'autres marques à
janet jackson on ferme le dossier tac
tac on se lave les mains quel point on
aime bien très bien aussi
manu tu avais pas de remarques sur son
comportement toi qui aime bien regarder
ça rien qu'il ya eu mais sur le terrain
on a marre maintenant sur le banc sur
les enfants et sur le carreau ok on
imagine à l'échauffement un mec qui
donne beaucoup
ce qui ne veut rien dire évidemment on
l'a tous vécu c'est l'heure c'est là
deux chroniques teupen l'obsession de
ben
[Musique]
millas
m
le ciel
ce sens
vincent clerc
alors benoît j'ai besoin de savoir qui
tu me parles comme ben ghaith de vie
signe ou qui jouent d'un match madness
qui est un joueur très étrange comme tu
sais comme mais comme je les aime les
dom et nichane island surnommé bones
parce qu'il était vraiment très
maigrichon à lorsqu'il était au lycée il
est plus maigrichon maintenant il fait
190 dit il ça fait combien 89 kg -
prennent un peu plus pour un poste en
u2 c'est respectable il fait 6 390 et
nationale est un bon jusqu'aux verts
mais pas une excellente car il n'est pas
un bon passeur c'est pas un jour 2 passe
par là il est humaine
il y rejoint défensif incroyable non
plus parce qu'il manque de coffre mais
la chambre il a un don de dieu pour
finir notre trafic
il est absolument incroyable pour finir
des choix difficiles parfois après
contact or dit qu'il y avait que trois
défenseurs dessus ces magiciens du tiers
difficile et pour ça c'est lorsqu'il qui
ne s'apprend pas de finir aussi bien
dans le trafic de pouvoir se
contorsionner pour éviter contact ou
pour travailler au delà du contact et
pouvoir finir aussi avec autant de grâce
et de faciliter ce qui me fait croire
que malgré le fait qu'ils soient entre
qu un joueur correct et ordinaire
autrement il place pour lui un billet
parce que c'est ce qui est difficile à
prendre un billet de freiner avec autant
de vigueur et de facilité moi j'adore
regarder bonsaï la de jouer parce que
c'est un joueur à touques et que 99 % de
finish adultes pointé
ils les 65% au cercle
ah ouais mais il fait suer ses 65 %
c'est avec la cavalerie et le bordereau
la folie et pour les émissions et deux
pour les habituels du seigneur des
anneaux l'aï là ils sauront qui lui
colle au cul il est capable de finir
s'est écrasé à l'année mois on a parfois
le sait c'est un des joueurs il n'y a
pas un saint
c'est alors je crois que le petit mil
qui avait mis la vidéo sur twitter il
offre un son son coéquipier atteint 3
points il prend le rebond au vol il
prend le temps de mettre ses pieds prend
le rebond au voile il finit il tombe sur
le q3 point boumahni fait cesser sa joie
presque et qui fait des trucs choc des
matches il a dû toucher
vous avez vu vous avez vous en pensez
quoi va déjà moi je l'aimé je les ai pas
vus je n'ai pas vu l'atlantique c'était
sans moi cette année malheureusement
mais je regarde les stats brut
je vois huit tentatives à trois points
par match 37% 86 % aux lancers francs
sur cinq tentatives par match et jeudi
j'achète le shooteur déjà si tu me dit
en plus qu'il a dû toucher près du
cercle ça veut dire qu'ils la voient là
qu'il a dû toucher des choses qui
s'apprennent un peu moins que le reste
donc c'est interdit le don de dieu alex
il attendait plus que je touchais un don
de dieu et une apostrophe au milieu de
son prénom à la ned - donc là et j'ai
envie de dire qu'on verdure prévient
toujours parce qu'il était dans la liste
des dix fois moins à suivre
bon c'est vrai dès le début saison cette
année c'est vrai on avait mis son
identité son profil et mais franchement
de lille et en carrière quasiment 40% à
3 points sur il prend un tir de ces
tyrans poule up
à son âge il a augmenté aux lancers
francs cette année
ce mec c'est mettre des paniers il va il
va va jouer en nba
il est dans mon j'ai gelé au tout début
du deuxième tour pour l'instant mais
dans un tiers avec des mecs qui commence
dans les vins donc très très chaud sur
sur liste ou qu'il a pris des kilos
parce qu'il est 74 kg l'été dernier - il
n'est plus bomb
il n'est plus bon et jeux d'arènes
conférence que fans et saxo alto seul et
sera la mort il sera la march madness et
alors ce sera pour les couche tard on va
finir là-dessus match à g en train de
calculer quasiment deux heures du matin
heure française
mais ça va être hyper intéressant pour
les gens qui veulent suivre un peu la
draft puisque d'un côté on aura de
bonnes salades et de l'autre on aura
origone avec chris duarte et ils vont
certainement défendre l'un sur l'autre
un moment donné évidemment friend of de
programmes qu'on adore ici mais mais
voilà origone bcu
c'est dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
je pense donc
donc voilà la march madness va commencer
je vous refais le topo l'arche madness
va commencer y aura pas à zahia jackson
on vient de vous faire son footing
report notre big board et sur le site
vous pouvez aller consulter les profils
des joueurs évidemment aussi sur le site
envergure point c'est au vous pouvez
allez noter nos podcasts sur la plate
forme de votre choix et vous pouvez nous
envoyer évidemment des compliments en
message privé puisque on adore ça
voilà merci beaucoup à tous
vous pouvez dire à l'amener à quel point
les ball oui mais surtout sur les vidéos
force team aller à yayi a les ponce et
tennessee gonzaga qu'on va suivre de
près à la march madness évidemment
surtout pierre qui a suivi tennessee
toute la saison
merci pierre évidemment pour ta dispo ce
soir c'était interdire
et puis c'est bien et puis voilà à
bientôt à la prochaine semaine prochaine
un nouveau podcast
ça va régaler ciao à lui
[Musique]